Y vamos a resolver el problema 33,
que dice,
encuentra una recta
que sea paralela a la siguiente recta,
"y" igual a -5/4 de "x" más 2.
Y bueno, dos rectas son paralelas si tienen
la misma pendiente y en este caso,
que tenemos una recta en la forma
pendiente ordenada al origen,
la pendiente es el coeficiente que está a lado de "x",
es decir que mi pendiente es igual a -5/4.
Por lo tanto, tengo que encontrar una recta
que tenga una pendiente de -5/4
y como tendría la misma pendiente,
entonces serían paralelas.
Bueno, en mis incisos, el inciso A dice,
"y" es igual a -5/4 de "x" más 1 y por lo tanto,
esta es mi repuesta,
porque ya tenemos la misma pendiente,
lo único distinto es que corta
al eje de las "y" en un punto distinto.
Por lo tanto la respuesta es el inciso A
y ahora vamos a hacer el problema 34.
Así que mejor déjame copiarlo
y pegarlo por aquí...
y entonces...
aquí está, perfecto.
¿Cuál es la gráfica que representa la solución
de este sistema de desigualdades?
Y tengo estas dos desigualdades,
así que tengo 4 gráficas
y yo lo que quiero saber es,
¿cuál es la gráfica que representa
este sistema de desigualdades?
Y bueno, no queda de otra,
vamos a tomar la primera desigualdad
y vamos a empezar a trabajar con ella,
a ver qué nos queda.
Entonces tengo "2x" esto es
mayor o igual que "y" menos 1,
y ahora si yo quiero despejar a "y" de aquí,
lo que voy a hacer es sumar 1
de ambos lados de la desigualdad
y me queda que "2x" más 1
es mayor o igual que "y".
Y bueno, esto es exactamente lo mismo...
y lo voy a poner un poco más ordenado,
que "y" es menor o igual que "2x" más 1,
¿qué quiere decir esto?
Que si nosotros nos fijamos en la recta
que corta al eje de las "y" en 1
y que tiene una pendiente de 2,
entonces queremos todas las "y" que sean
menor o igual que esta recta,
esta recta corta en el eje de las "y" en 1
y tiene una pendiente de 2,
porque si caminamos 2 a la derecha, subimos 4, entonces ésta puede ser un candidato de nuestra recta,
sin embargo, estamos buscando
el conjunto de solución
que sea más chico que eso
por lo tanto ésta no puede ser.
Ésta de aquí si funciona porque tenemos
una pendiente igual a 2,
cortamos en "y" igual a 1,
pero lo mejor de todo esto es que la
parte sombreada es menor que esta recta,
que es justo lo que quería,
ésta nos sirve porque la parte sombreada
es mayor que esta recta
y por lo tanto yo lo que quiero
es que "y" sea menor que esta recta,
aquí me estoy tomando "y" mayores,
si te das cuenta, cualquier punto de esta parte sombreada cumple que es menor que esta recta,
que mi recta
"y" igual a "2x" más 1
Entonces esta podría funcionar, pero espera...
tenemos otras dos gráficas,
éstas dos de aquí abajo y si te das cuenta,
tenemos la misma recta,
el único problema y la única diferencia,
es que aquí tenemos a todas las "y"
que sean menores que esa recta,
mientras que del otro lado,
tenemos a todas las "y"
que sean mayores que esa recta,
fíjate bien como aquí quedamos en la parte de abajo
de esta recta y en este inciso D,
también estamos en la parte de abajo de esta recta,
aquí en el inciso D,
también puede ser nuestra solución.
Entonces como no sabemos si es el inciso C o el D, fijémonos en nuestra siguiente desigualdad...
¡Oh no!
tenemos un problema,
no tenemos desigualdad,
¡qué raro está esto!
Déjame ver qué dice el problema...
¡Oh!
ya, ya, ya...
el problema dice
que nuestra respuesta es el inciso C,
por lo tanto un error tipográfico,
un error de dedo...
aquí no pusieron desigualdad...
Vamos a ver qué desigualdad tendríamos que tener para que nos dé de respuesta el inciso C.
¡Wow!
este problema creo que ya está quedando mejor,
fíjate bien en esta recta,
yo lo que quiero es que ésta de aquí...
ahora en lo que me voy a fijar,
es en esta cosa que tenemos aquí, quiero saber
si esto es mayor o igual, menor o igual o igual o
¿qué pasa con esto?
Entonces, ahora la pregunta se cambió.
Ya sabemos que la mejor gráfica
o la gráfica que es la solución
de este sistema de ecuaciones es la C,
vamos a ver qué símbolo necesitamos aquí
para que nuestra respuesta correcta sea la C.
Entonces aquí en este circulito,
es justo lo que estoy buscando
o un mayor o igual
o un menor o igual.
Y para esto lo que voy a hacer primero
es sumar "5y" de ambos lados de la ecuación,
para poco a poco ir despejando "y".
Así que, ¿qué me va a quedar si yo sumo
"5y" de ambos lados de la ecuación, desigualdad...?
no sé que sea esto.
Entonces me quedaría, "2x", circulito,
recuerda que este circulito es precisamente
lo que quiero saber,
si es mayor o igual,
o menor o igual "10y" más 5...
Y ahora lo que voy a hacer es pasar este 10
del otro lado de la...
cosa, con el signo contrario, me quedaría "2x" menos "y" circulito es igual a "5y",
recuerda que este circulito es lo que no sabemos,
que por cierto, no puede ser un signo de igual
porque tenemos una región,
entonces o es mayor o igual,
o es menor o igual...
o no te queda de otra...
Entonces para esto lo que voy a hacer
es dividir todo entre 5 y me queda,
"2x" entre 5
menos 2 es algo de "y".
Y ya aquí, ya tengo despejada a "y"
y por lo tanto,
lo que quiero
es la región que sea ¿qué?
Bueno, lo que quiero buscar en este circulito,
es una región que sea más grande que esta ecuación,
si te das cuenta,
quedamos arriba de esta recta.
Me dice que mi conjunto-solución tiene que estar abajo de esta desigualdad que tengo de morado,
pero a su vez,
tiene que estar arriba de esta recta y por lo tanto,
si quiero que esté arriba de esta recta,
entonces aquí tengo que poner,
mayor que...
No, no, no, espera, espera...
No mayor que,
porque en lo que me fijo es en la "y",
por lo tanto la "y" es la que tiene que ser más grande
que esta expresión que tengo aquí.
Es decir, que para que la respuesta de
mi problema sea el inciso C,
yo tengo que tener aquí el símbolo de menor que,
para que mi respuesta sea la C,
"2x" menos "5y" tiene que ser menor
que 10 ó dicho de otra manera,
2/5 de "x" menos 2
tiene que ser menor que "y".
Justo con esto entramos
a la región del inciso C
y date cuenta que esta región no funciona porque aquí pasa justamente lo contrario,
estamos arriba de la recta
que no queríamos estar arriba,
queríamos estar abajo y del otro lado,
estamos abajo de la recta,
que queríamos estar arriba,
por lo tanto esta es la región opuesta.
En fin, vamos a resolver
otro problema de este examen...
mejor déjame borrar todo esto,
pasarlo por acá...
y vamos a hacer otro problema.
Espero que este problema si tenga solución o la menos no la tengamos que modificar, perfecto,
aquí está.
¿Cuál es la solución del sistema de ecuaciones?
Y aquí tengo dos ecuaciones,
un sistema de dos ecuaciones con dos incógnitas
y tengo cuatro incisos.
Ahora bien, para encontrar la solución de
este sistema de ecuaciones,
lo que voy a hacer de esta ecuación de aquí arriba es pasarla de la siguiente manera,
voy a sumar "3x" de ambos lados de la ecuación,
de tal manera que me queda "3x" más "y" es igual a -2.
No te asustes,
lo único que hice fue sumar 3...
déjame ponerlo con otro color...
"3x" de ambos lados de la ecuación
y si sumo "3x" de ambos lados de la ecuación
estos dos se cancelan.
Y bueno,
llego a esta ecuación de aquí.
Y...
¡Oh!
¿ya te diste cuenta?
Lo que quiero enseñarte es que
estamos hablando de la misma recta dos veces,
si esta recta de acá arriba la multiplico por 2,
de ambos lados de la ecuación, ¿a qué llego?
Fíjate bien que voy a llegar a la misma
expresión de la ecuación de aquí abajo,
entonces voy a multiplicar por 2 esta parte y me queda,
2 por "3x" es "6x", 2 por "y" me queda "2y"
y esto es igual, voy a multiplicar por 2 también
el otro lado de la ecuación,
a -2 por 2 lo cual es -4.
¿Y qué crees?
Son exactamente iguales esta recta y la recta
que acabo de encontrar, ésta de aquí.
Por lo tanto,
estamos hablando de la misma recta
y cuando yo quiero encontrar la solución
de un sistema de ecuaciones,
estoy buscando en dónde se intersectan,
pero si son la misma recta,
entonces se intersectan en cada uno de sus puntos, porque son la misma recta,
es decir, tenemos
una infinidad de soluciones,
porque todos sus puntos
son solución de este sistema.
Así que vamos a hacer otro problema más.
Ya tengo aquí mi espacio y voy a copiar
y pegar el siguiente problema,
que es éste de aquí,
éste...
Oh no espera...
éste de aquí.
Tengo este par de ecuaciones
y yo lo que quiero encontrar
es la solución
de este sistema de ecuaciones.
Y para esto creo que lo mejor es hacer el
método de suma y resta,
lo que voy a hacer es
multiplicar la ecuación de abajo por -1,
de tal manera que la ecuación de arriba me queda,
"x" más "3y" igual a 7,
a ésta no le hice nada.
Y a la de acá abajo le voy a cambiar a todo el signo,
es decir, la voy a multiplicar por -1,
¿y qué me queda?
Menos por "x" me queda "-x", menos por "2y"
me queda "-2y" y menos por 10 me queda -10.
Y ahora si, si sumo este par de ecuaciones,
ya voy a encontrar la solución de este
sistema de ecuaciones de una manera muy sencilla.
Fíjate bien, vamos a utilizar el método
de suma y resta y vamos a sumar estas dos ecuaciones,
de tal manera que la "x" se va a cancelar,
entonces, estos dos se cancelan,
"x" menos "x" se cancelan y después me queda,
"3y" menos "2y" es lo mismo que "y",
y del otro lado tengo 7 menos 10,
7 menos 10 es lo mismo que -3 ó 3 negativo.
Sí, sí, sí...
tengo 7 pesos pero debo 10,
pues entonces
termino debiendo 3 pesos...
Perfecto, ya tengo el valor de "y",
ahora lo que voy a hacer es sustituir el valor de "y"
en la ecuación de arriba, para encontrar el valor de "x".
Entonces me queda, "x" más 3 por "y",
pero "y" vale -3,
entonces me quedaría "x" más 3 por -3 es igual a 7
y si de aquí multiplico 3 por -3, me queda -9,
esto es igual a 7 y ahora sumando 9
de ambos lados de la ecuación,
me queda que "x" es igual a 7 más 9,
lo cual es 16.
Ya tengo el punto de intersección de estas
dos rectas, es el punto (16, -3)
ó cuando "x" vale 16,
"y" vale igual a -3 y aquí tengo la solución.
Así que vamos a hacer
el último problema de este video.
El último problema
que es este problema de aquí.
Y dice así,
Marta colecciona monedas de 10 centavos
y de 25 centavos y en total tiene 100 monedas.
Si la suma del dinero de todas sus monedas
es de 14 pesos con 5 centavos,
¿cuántas monedas de 25 centavos tiene?
Así que vamos a escribir las ecuaciones
que resuelven este sistema.
"d" más "q" es decir,
la cantidad de monedas de 10 centavos
más la cantidad de monedas de 25 centavos,
tiene que ser igual a 100
porque tenemos 100 monedas.
Y por otra parte,
lo que valen las monedas de 10 centavos,
es decir, .10 de peso,
por la cantidad de monedas de 10 centavos
más .25 por la cantidad
de monedas de 25 centavos,
esto tiene que ser igual a la cantidad de
dinero que tenemos, en pesos, 14.05 pesos.
Y perfecto, ya con esto tenemos un sistema de ecuaciones con dos incógnitas y con dos ecuaciones,
utilizando los dos datos
que me da el problema.
Y yo quiero saber
cuántas monedas de 25 centavos tengo,
así que para esto
y para resolver este sistema de ecuaciones,
voy a aplicar el método de suma y resta
y lo que voy a hacer es de esta ecuación de acá arriba...
a esta ecuación de acá arriba
la voy a multiplicar por -.1 o por -.10
para que se cancele con este .10
que tenemos aquí abajo,
entonces vamos a multiplicarlo por -.1.
Y me queda "-.1d"...
".1d" ó "-.10d"... es lo mismo...
menos, más por menos es menos,
"-.10q" esto es igual a 100 por -.1,
solo hay que recorrer el punto y me va a quedar -10...
-10... es decir, estamos dividiendo el 100
en 10 pedacitos y me queda -10.
Ok y ahora voy a sumar estas dos ecuaciones
y vamos a ver qué me queda.
Estos dos ".10d" menos ".10d" se van, se cancelan,
es justo lo que yo quería,
por otra parte tengo más ".25q" menos ".10q",
pues esto es ".15q", hasta aquí vamos bien
y eso tiene que ser igual a 14.05 menos 10
y 14.05 menos 10, es lo mismo que 4.05
y aquí vamos bastante bien,
ya casi acabamos el problema,
porque hay que dividir todo entre .15
para encontrar la respuesta.
Pero como no me gusta el punto decimal voy
a multiplicar todo por 100 de una vez
y me queda que "15q" es igual a 405...
esto es lo mismo...
y después ahora voy a dividir todo entre 15,
entonces me queda que "q" es igual a 405 entre 15 que, ¿cuánto es?
15 cabe 2 veces en 40, 2 por 15 es 30 y 40
menos 30 va a ser 10, entonces aquí me queda 10,
bajo el 5 y
¿15 cuántas veces cabe en 105?
Pues es 30, 60, 90 y 1, 7, perfecto,
7 veces, 7 por 15, curiosamente es 105
y entonces esto me da exacto
y ya tenemos la respuesta.
"q" es igual a 27, es decir, la cantidad de monedas que tengo de 25 centavos es 27.